in this capsule we will see some
definitions related to learning
automatic
so we said that learning
automatic is interested in development
of algorithms that will allow a
agent adapt from data for
improve its performance and data
in fact, it will correspond to
sets we see losers very
coveted x an associated target
sponsored then recommended what we
will show them this data there we go
assume that our input x is going
finally match a vector of values
where each of the values ​​is going to be
attributes corresponded real that describes
a given object we have an example here are
wanted to represent an image whose
will represent by a vector that will
actually contain attributes that
correspond each of the values ​​of
the intensity of each of the peaks is therefore
we have an image here of a character e where
each of the pixels actually took a
business value to heroes or a tax
also to both languages ​​06 opodo and one
fir tree in python could represent his
share a table where we would have each
pixels and during the peaks she who was
chosen here is an order where we pass
tidy up after storage so we have plenty of
0.6 point 06.06.09 is 1.2 more
forgiveness so here one here correspond
to the blacks here we would have 6 1 6 2 so we
will assume
for any problem that can be taken
your objects he is represented under the
shape of a vector a vector of values
who each have values ​​it's a
attribute associated with our object and
now the desired exit made me the
representation that we will use with
different depending on the problem to be solved
and we are going to focus on a bonus
classification in these classes
different so big six meters the
number of classes that interests us
we want to distinguish and in this case also
well the value there is going to take a value
who discreet who will belong to the
whole from scratch up to his means
if we index the categories
classes from zero to big his
means
so we will associate with each of
possible categories a value of 0.6
what a great way her if we did the
character recognition but one
would each take abcd characters
up to z for example and then we
some but making a computer unreliable
would associate my heart with that
could be the zero class
bessat near the class an institute on
could also by regression so
in this case also in regression the target
will match a real value so
in a continuous way so
general and on regression
we will not see the next catches
but know that it's a problem too
con to try to attack he has
that can be solved with learning
automatic
now we said we will be interested
especially at learning supervise there
we will define a little more with our
notation for entries and targets
what do we mean by
learning ferries and so after a
learning supervise it's going maybe
the problem of and gave a set
great workout an example so
having a set will contain the loses
entry and convoy targets listed
so etc without wearing our first
example of training exist two greek
2 our second training example
up to x grant ny quarantine so to
from 7 years training at the hague
where we will assume that there have been
generated by a function that we do not
does not know an unknown function
convince the pharmacies what we want
it's an algorithm able to discover
a new function h
this official we will call him a
perfect model say it's a
hypothesis that is going to be a good
approximation of our unknown function
f
so we're going to want that h2x that's going to be
the prediction made by our model
after loaned trained on our
training data
we were hoping we would want hdx
as close as possible to f2 x is
so in fact a welcome learning
we will be able to
it's like a function we're going
call big to whom we give a
wavy driving set that can
to be an argument of the gold function that
noted place of learning and seven
officials will be returned a
function that will be our model h
our model driven on our data
training that I benefit from
to clarify some things in the
notation
so firstly i'm going to use x in
big so a big letter for
denote either vectors or
matrices elima sadly I'm going
use a capital letter when
is going to talk about matrix and I'm going to use
rather italic when I'm going to do
reference to a variable that corresponds
in fact to a scanner then finally the
function fdx did it's a function
is known and this function can
to match a little anything that
could be a program that we try
of proximity or it could be the one
that typically makes it anyway a
human being who if we take the example of
character classification or
character recognition a being
human who would have seen an image x and who
have identified that the identity of the
character in the picture
ok so function here it's not
necessarily a function as a
polynomial something like that it's
really anything that takes a
input and that provides an output that
we are interested and in intelligence
artificial more often than not
the function in question is an expert
or a human being we want
model the behavior
ok so that's going to be our definition
more mathematical problem
of supervising learning and of our
definition for what is a
learning algorithms so
General